what is up boys and girls it has been a
while how do you do it's Jerry in case
you've forgotten I was you know I
wouldn't blame you it's been a couple
weeks now on anyhow I I just got out of
the amazing spider-man two electric
boogaloo so these are my first
impressions as I'm sure you're aware uh
so I going into this movie I was
actually kind of not excited because
I've gotten so sick of their ad campaign
over the last like you know like it's
cool to get excited about about movies
and stuff like that and see a trailer
and anticipate and all that but there's
something about the advertising for this
movie I was like okay we get it calm
down please people will see your movie I
promit it's spider-man like so yeah it's
like I've / trailer after trailer after
trailer and Clement for cliff after
cliff it was like guys oh stop like what
is left of this movie to see at this
point and um I'm happy to report that
there is a good amount left to see
there's a lot left to see um this movie
is pitched at least as I took it to be
much more while it doesn't always manage
its balancing act it does for a lot of
it for most of it all the performance is
a really good Andrew Garfield and Emma
Stone are fantastic together Sally Field
maybe cheer up a little bit one of those
moments Dane DeHaan it took me a few
minutes to get used to date on but but
what it really gets going with him I
thought he did a great job Jamie Foxx
does a really good job especially with
humanizing that character with as many
other things as there are two do um so
you know this movie tries to do a whole
lot of things and for the most part I
think it does there's more human drama
in his one that I was expecting and I
quite like that because that was my
favorite stuff and then when they would
put in a giant action set piece um that
satisfied my geeky you know like ooh
things are blowing up quota cuz you know
that stuff can get tiring the effects
are really good of course all the
actions
good um and you know exciting there's a
lot of really cool little sequences
where the cinematography gets very
stylized which I very much appreciate it
and they also do they go to some lengths
to make things like sound and even music
figure in but like practically on screen
most of which I thought were really cool
not like montage music but like you'll
see because of electro and all the
electrical objects and machines and
stuff in the city they play with those
in some little ways that I thought were
really neat so that was also something I
I appreciated but this movies like they
really made it about their characters
and you know the relationship especially
between a peter and i almost said Mary
Jane Peter and Gwen Peter and Gwen um
and they do more with his you know
parental backstory and stuff like that
it's maybe it's just because I was led
to believe this going in but it it
doesn't to me at least feel like
spider-man 3 in the sense of like aw
they've got four villains and they're
doing all this [ __ ] rough-and-tumble
flashbang you know action action action
um and there is action but it seemed to
me like they aired more on the side of
you know the human stories and stuff
like that there are some really cool set
pieces but at least from where I'm
standing right now it doesn't feel
bloated and especially having seen some
of the reviews going in I know it's it
like 58 or something on rotten tomatoes
right now so I kept kind of expecting it
to fall into spider-man 3 territory
which is a movie I don't hate spider-man
3 has some great parts if it doesn't
work together as a whole um so this
movie kept drifting into territory rows
like up here it comes you know like some
characters gonna get slighted or you
know they're gonna try and do too much
and for the most part there were a few
moments basically the movie kept making
me wonder if it was gonna do certain
things where it kept almost losing me
towards the end and then getting me back
in a sense because there were a number
of moments here and there where I would
be like up here we go here's ending
43 and then moments later it would be
like but no I'm really invested in this
again um so I think they did a good job
overall there there are some moments of
clunky dialogue and there are some
moments where it feels like developments
are a little too quick so that those are
kind of places in which the sheer amount
of things are trying to get done do sort
of way things down but those moments are
much less than the moments that do work
and that are you know thrilling and that
are engrossing so yeah I'm feeling
pretty positive on this I dug it man so
I'm and the 3d was good I I didn't
realize I was going to a 3d screening
but I did and it was good I actually you
know found myself going oh it's 3d like
I'm not upset i paid the extra three
bucks so um so yeah I'd say definitely
definitely check out spider-man
especially if you're a fan I mean I
don't know I don't have a lot of comic
book knowledge but I quite enjoyed this
so um that's it for now it's my first
impressions and let's let's go back
let's talk about spider-man let's say um
out of all five spider-man movies we
have now which one do you think is the
most successful or do you think any of
them are successful and why um see ya
that's it for now uh amazing spider-man
2 is the flick and until next time I am
still Jerry contrary to popular belief
and cheers
also I did feel a little bit like Randy
from A Christmas Story during the
credits you'll see I'm not gonna spoil
anything but you'll see but yeah credits
also in 3ds so that was good